shot clock is on James pull up for a
three that's the wait in the house
you do exactly what he was doing just
mute the clock
said here it comes splash drop flushes
snuck all this to Dorothy
there's no place like home spectacular
finish by LeBron
better be tilted by the Lakers that get
off it
by the stanchion he'll get a free throw
running downfield
number 23 you are clear for takeoff as
LeBron goes one-on-one got a buck I mean
he's had three passes and I could really
been special links think he's gonna take
the shot good movement without the ball
again this time by Lonzo and the pun
says I thought if you're moving I see
you presented the first quarter well
it's too early to do the other two
finish it off here on again leading the
way powering two of his 13 points here
comes LeBron
[Applause]
threw it up sometimes when you hear the
whistle just throw it up if you just do
it up and do with righty
[Applause]
[Music]
down is LeBron James kids say enough
about to change the direction off the
dribble we went to the rim and he
finished about the rim
[Applause]
the stairs of the fetish James Worthy
statue is everything
[Applause]
with seven with six and here's LeBron
LeBron for the time
[Applause]
the prod with the clock winding down
long three-pointer it looks different
from last year oh those high sends it
back install skits
now LeBron on the other coast to coast
take it over Staples Center
[Applause]
block by LeBron on a defensive end
offensive the spindle
I love LA